hi I'm got a lotta bay my name is Ayaka
hi I'm Sarah I'm from the New York area
and I'm from Japan today we're gonna try
Japanese and New York cheesecake
first of all Japanese cheesecake is the
best cheesecake in the world we have the
selections okay oh we have a Vegas guy
oh yes super cheesecake you know
jiggle-jiggle cheesecake I heard about
that jiggly cheesecake yeah
Japanese people are really into pastries
and sweets I had once actually someone
brought them to work and I had a bite I
had it briefly I had a brief morsel a
mouthful first of all I'm a New Yorker
so I like my cheesecake just as a simple
regular cheesecake I don't need no extra
strawberries on that no caramel it's
good the way it is
I like cheesecake but keep it simple son
I live in New York before and I have
four cheesecakes bolts that I go to all
the time and like Cheesecake Factory
right does that New York so you guys I
love you to sell cheesecake I've been
eating it forever
[Music]
yeah I'm gonna let you go first okay
make sure you get the crust whoa it's so
creamy I think the course a little
harder than what it is yeah it's really
nice it's really rich dense mmm I like
the crust the crust is very light the
crust is really just forming this into a
circle shape so you can eat it it's
really not doing much else and that's
you know what it should be doing yeah
mmm what do you think it's so just
moisture it's like really heavy really
heavy and heavy and a heavy that's it
you don't like a heavy what I like them
you know but not the main thing for me
you're not you like I was silly though
cheesecake is nice for people like me
cuz I'm not a big cake person mm-hmm I
gotta like sweets either but it's not
really that sweet a savory it's not a
sickly sweet as like icing it's still
got like a cheesy flavor to it where it
doesn't feel
as same home the cheesy flavor feels
from very simple though I think you know
cuz it's rich uh true hmm that's fair I
check it back it's just so sugary and a
creamy and a heavy that's America
[Music]
everything is just too much everything
is too much okay you want a little no
but yeah a little bit less would be
better feet
that's my last are you still eating it
see it's a big thing Young is working
she's like yeah whatever but she keep
eating it you see that no sir I'm
searing it that's what my New York is yo
[Music]
looks like bread hmm interesting
this is different to the one I feel like
I've had before
Wow this
it was like the baby of the other
cheesecake yeah a small boy
it looks like more fluffier yeah let's
dig in
they actually sell cheesecake and
convenience stores in Japan they just
sell it like bread in little packs
I've got against Japan so it's a lot
different than the New York style
cheesecake because it has the texture of
bread I'm interested great yeah okay
this one is very gentle like it feels
very like I feel like I would feel gross
having a slice of New York cheesecake
with like a cup of tea but this looks
like something you could just be like
decide to have and not feel gross about
it cuz feels like it does cut like a
like a cheesecake it's like picking up
clouds definitely ya know there's
amazing this is so bad this is really
good I think I was thrown off by the
initial texture in the beginning hmm
it's kind of crumbly in the New York
cheesecake cheese is the predominant
flavor but in this cake is the
predominant flavor and then there's just
like a whisper of cheese you know it's
it's certainly not bad I want to knock
this it's cake it's can't get good it's
like a bread oh you know no like super
cheese cake style it feels more breading
yeah there's more of a bread I like how
it's not too sweet to be honest so I
kind of like this cheese cake a lot
better than the other one this tastes
like a pound cake well you ever had like
a pound cake like yeah yeah it's kind of
like that it's like the light it's like
a lighter pound cake and it tricks you
because it looks like cheesecake but
then you eat it and it's just cake it
kind of tastes like the 7-eleven
cheesecake and it was like a weird egg
flavor too
yeah yeah I was like a very strange egg
undertone
yeah like this I really like this it's
crazy because it's more like if it is
soft its smooth when you cut in the
middle is like is very very soon I don't
mind that it's calling itself cheesecake
cuz I can taste the cheese I just feel
like I'm not a person who looks for cake
so that's why I
go to it if it was just called Japanese
cake at all maybe I would actually cuz I
really like Japanese stuff
and it was good I prefer the mayor stuff
I'm going New York tomorrow I'm probably
gonna eat cheesecake tomorrow - I think
I like the job because one better I like
the texture better this is y'all I'm
sorry I'm eating the last one okay you
eat this all the time my first time
eating this see I told you this is
really good yeah high five yeah to Japan
hey I love you guys
yes there's a fan football
[Music]